bonjour à tous
et bonne année 2023 à chacun d'entre
vous et à vos familles et vos proches
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro des
grands débats nous allons revoir l'année
parlementaire à travers un moment phare
à l'Assemblée nationale les questions au
Gouvernement chaque semaine lorsque le
Parlement siège les députés interrogent
les ministres sur l'actualité politique
économique sociale au titre de leur
pouvoir de contrôle de l'exécutif alors
nous sommes en janvier 2023 un sujet et
dans tous les esprits la réforme des
retraites annoncées par le gouvernement
une réforme qui résonne fortement à
l'Assemblée nationale l'hémicycle va
devenir un lieu d'affrontement central
entre d'un côté la majorité qui fait
bloc autour de la réforme du
gouvernement et de l'autre des
oppositions déterminées à dénoncer et à
lutter contre une réforme jugée injuste
cette réforme elle doit être efficace
lorsqu'on parle de retraite on parle
d'âge chacun pense immédiatement à l'âge
et refuser comme certains voudraient le
faire de ne pas de parler de l'âge ce
serait éclipsé le débat un peu comme si
on parlait de mariage sans parler
d'amour
gouverner c'est affronté la réalité je
comprends bien que l'augmentation de
l'âge de départ fasse politiquement peur
mais la politique c'est d'abord du
courage augmenter l'âge de départ c'est
changer le regard de notre société sur
le travail à ce titre le rôle de chaque
entreprise est fondamentale le degré
d'implication des entreprises dans la
durée conditionne le succès de la
réforme et les pouvoirs publics devront
accompagner les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent le faire ainsi
monsieur le ministre je n'ai aucun doute
que le dialogue avec les entreprises est
aujourd'hui fructueux je voudrais
simplement au travers de cette réponse
pouvoir avec vous le vérifier votre
question me permet d'abord de répéter de
souligner l'importance qu'il y a amené
cette réforme pour établir l'équilibre
du régime de retraite j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire à maintes
améliorer le déficit son équilibré n'est
pas responsable l'équilibré sans
l'améliorer serait injuste et donc c'est
bien l'amélioration et l'équilibre que
nous recherchons nous le faisons dans le
lien le social avec tous les partenaires
sociaux ils ont tous participé au
concertation que nous avons mené au
cours des dernières semaines nous avons
construit des convergences nous avons
aussi acté un certain nombre de
désaccords et la transparence du
dialogue social de la démocratie sociale
commande aussi de dire lorsqu'il y a des
accords ou différents et tout simplement
les assumer
sur deux se dit révolter
cial un niveau jamais enregistré depuis
24 ans alors dans ce contexte
pensez-vous sincèrement madame la
Première ministre qu'il est bon pour le
pays de débuter cette année on nous
proposant tout à l'heure une réforme des
retraites en vue de décaler l'âge de
départ à la retraite à laquelle 70% des
Français sont opposés le gouvernement
parle de courage mais ça n'est pas du
courage de faire payer aux Français et
en particulier à ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt les échecs des politiques
de ces dernières années pour pérenniser
notre modèle de retraite il faut d'une
part relancer la natalité et d'autre
part créer des emplois de qualité pour
enfin relancer la productivité de notre
économie
alors je vous confirme madame la
Présidente que notre objectif l'objectif
de mon gouvernement c'est de protéger
les Français c'est de les protéger face
à la hausse des prix de l'énergie c'est
le sens du bouclier tarifaire c'est le
sens des mesures pour les entreprises
pour les collectivités que nous avons
porté dès cet été dans le paquet pouvoir
d'achat et dans les textes financiers
adoptés à la fin de l'année et je note
madame la Présidente que le
rassemblement national a voté contre
tous ces textes et par ailleurs madame
la Présidente nous protégeons notre
économie nous protégeons les Français
aujourd'hui mais nous protégeons aussi
l'avenir des Français l'avenir de nos
retraites et c'est le sens du projet de
justice d'équilibre et de solidarité que
je présenterai dans les prochaines
heures je vous remercie
madame la Première ministre pour la
première fois je manifesterai ce jeudi
contre la réforme des retraites pour une
raison simple votre réforme est injuste
car elle repose sur le report de l'âge
légal de départ nous avons dit notre
désaccord sur ce constat notre système
se rend déficit ses prochaines années
mais il n'est pas en péril nous avons
dit notre désaccord sur la méthode et le
calendrier une réforme menée sans
concertation suffisante et au moment où
les Français souffrent notre désaccord
sur le choix de ne pas laisser le
Parlement prendre le temps d'examiner et
de voter un texte si important notre
désaccord enfin sur vos propositions
vous avez entendu sur les 65 ans c'est
une satisfaction mais 64 ans reste très
injuste le poids de votre réforme pèsera
sur les classes populaires et moyennes
sur celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt toutes ces injustices ne
sont pas comblées par le dispositif
carrière longue largement incomplet et
vous le savez très peu de carrière
permett une retraite minimale 2200 euros
madame le Premier ministre vous nous
avez dit que la concertation continuait
vous nous vous demandons et les Français
aussi de supprimer cette mesure de
reportage légal à 64 ans nous avons déjà
parlé de la nécessité d'un grand plan
senior à quoi cela sert-il d'obliger les
gens à travailler plus longtemps alors
qu'ils sont privés d'emploi c'est ce que
disait le président de la République il
y a 5 ans enfin je pose la question de
la recherche de nouveaux financement au
sein même de votre majorité des
propositions apparaissent en résumé
madame la Première ministre pour éviter
une crise sociale majeure allez-vous
enfin écouter les responsables syndicaux
et nos concitoyens l'effet c'est que
depuis début octobre les organisations
syndicales et patronales ont été reçus à
de multiples reprises par le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft et moi-même
l'effet c'est que j'ai rencontré chaque
président de groupe parlementaire à
plusieurs reprises sur ce texte et dans
ce cadre monsieur le Président pencher
nous avons échangé trois fois alors les
faits sont là cette réforme n'a pas été
menée dans la précipitation mais dans la
concertation
nous avons un objectif
préserver notre système par répartition
et là encore l'effet sont têtus le
nombre d'actifs par rapport au nombre de
retraités baisse il y avait deux actifs
pour un retraité en 2005 il y a il y en
a aujourd'hui
1,7 et demain 1,5 nous devons donc
rétablir l'équilibre de notre système de
retraite monsieur le Président pencheur
vous me demandez si j'ai des tabous j'ai
plutôt des convictions et des réponses
je suis d'accord avec vous notre système
doit prendre en compte les différences
entre les métiers et entre les carrières
nous voulons un système juste un système
qui tient compte de celles et ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt celles et
ceux qui ont des carrières incomplètes
ou hachées celles et ceux qui ont des
métiers difficiles il serait les
premières victimes d'une absence de
réforme car notre système par
répartition les protège vous voulez
allonger la durée de cotisation et
reculez l'âge de départ de la retraite
mais vous ne proposez rien aux femmes de
55 ans et plus éloigné de l'emploi et
qui à cause de vous subiront le chômage
et la décote et vous osez parler de
progrès social mais pour qui madame la
Première ministre alors je pourrais vous
souffler une réponse vous voulez faire
18 milliards d'euros d'économies sur les
55 65 ans pour obéir au dogue des 3% du
pack de stabilité ce pacte qui met à
genoux nos économies qui met à mal notre
industrie qui menace nos démocraties et
nos modèles sociaux madame la Présidente
Chatelain nous avons par ailleurs un
enjeu majeur pour notre modèle social de
rétablir l'équilibre de notre système de
retraite parce que les personnes
fragiles les personnes modestes que dont
vous nous citer les exemples les
exemples que le ministre du Travail
qu'évidemment mon gouvernement et que
moi-même je vois
peuvent aujourd'hui s'appuyer sur un
système de retraite par répartition et
un système de répartition madame la
Présidente quand le nombre d'actifs et
désolé c'est une statistique quand le
nombre d'actifs qui finance une pension
quand on a deux actifs pour financer la
pension d'un retraité en 2005 1,7
aujourd'hui 1,5 demain je voudrais que
vous m'expliquer quel est le chemin
quelle est l'alternative à la réforme
que nous portons à la réforme que nous
portons de demander en effet
aux Français collectivement de
travailler progressivement plus
longtemps
la question très sensible du harcèlement
scolaire revient fréquemment lors des
questions au gouvernement le suicide de
Lucas 13 ans scolarisé dans les Vosges
et qui subissait un harcèlement en
raison de son homosexualité émeut la
représentation nationale la question des
violences entre bandes rivales est aussi
un sujet qui revient régulièrement lors
des questions du mardi
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse la question de notre
jeunesse est plurielle tant elle
représente notre diversité et notre
héritage elle est aussi la clé de voûte
de la société de demain mais aujourd'hui
quel avenir lui offrons-nous je sais que
cette question vous anime tout autant
que moi c'est pourquoi plus que d'y
réfléchir philosophiquement nous devons
d'y répondre concrètement
sans tomber dans les excès et les
raccourcis notre jeunesse nous expose
quotidiennement ses attentes ses peurs
et sa colère sa colère contre une
société qui détruit sa nature contre une
société où l'homophobie et les
discriminations existent encore une
société où les violents ou les jeunes
victimes et auteurs font face à de la
violence dans leur quotidien
l'actualité nous le rappelle encore
aujourd'hui et nous montre l'impact
qu'elle peut avoir sur leur comportement
et leur confiance il y a cinq ans déjà
je m'exprimais à ce même micro face à un
ministre différent certes mais sur le
même sujet si depuis 5 ans nous avons
nous pouvons noter plusieurs avancées
sur le harcèlement le code pénal des
mineurs le droit des enfants il est
toujours heureux pour moi de constater
qu'il y a encore tant à faire alors
Monsieur le Ministre donnant un coup de
pouce à cette jeunesse donnant lui
confiance en l'avenir car il y a une
qualité de que cette jeunesse garde
toujours c'est sa capacité à refuser un
futur incertain son optimisme et sa
persévérance redonne espoir
mobilisons-nous nous devons nous devons
de la protéger et de lui permettre de
s'épanouir et de s'émanciper c'est notre
devoir d'adultes mais c'est surtout
notre responsabilité d'hommes et de
femmes politiques et l'État doit en être
le garant
notre jeunesse peut-elle avoir confiance
en l'état
nos institutions sont-elles toujours en
phase avec ces attentes
quelle grande politique de protection de
prévention et d'accompagnement devant
nous mettre en place le jeune Lucas a
été victime de harcèlement en raison de
son homosexualité cette situation avait
été
identifiée prise en charge par son
collège mais cela n'a pas suffi à
l'évidence l'enquête déterminera les
causes et les circonstances exactes de
son suicide ainsi que les
responsabilités de chacun ce drame
mesdames et messieurs les députés
montrent à quel point la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire doit demeurer une
priorité du gouvernement la loi que vous
avez portée monsieur le député on a fait
un délit et accentuer la prise de
conscience de ce phénomène nous avons à
la rentrée généralisée le programme
phare dans toutes les écoles
élémentaires et tous les collèges mais
il est vrai qu'il nous reste encore
beaucoup à faire tant sur le plan de la
lutte
le harcèlement que du point de vue de la
lutte contre les l'homophobies c'est
pour cela que j'ai décidé dans les
prochaines semaines que devaient être
généralisé des groupes de
sensibilisation et de prévention contre
les LGBT phobies la haine anti LGBT est
absolument intolérable que ce soit à
l'école ou en dehors de l'école hier
vous l'avez dit Madame la député un
élève du lycée Guillaume Apollinaire de
de Thiais a été tué et un autre élève a
été blessé même si les premiers éléments
de l'enquête semblent montrer qu'il
s'agit d'une rixe entre élèves il est du
rôle de l'Éducation nationale de
signaler aux forces de l'ordre des
comportements d'élèves qui peuvent
amener à des faits de violence là encore
l'enquête précisera les faits
mardi 31 janvier une séance de questions
au Gouvernement pas comme les autres le
président de la Rada le Parlement
ukrainien est venu demander l'aide de la
France à son pays il prononce une
allocution à la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale
applaudissement et soutient unanime même
si certains émettent certaines réserves
mettant notamment en garde contre une
course aux armements en Europe
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début de cette agression à
grande échelle contre le Crète et avant
tout pour l'aide militaire
donnez-nous les avions
donne-nous les ailes de notre victoire
président Chassan vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre des enfants des femmes frappées
par les bombes jetées sur les routes par
millions des centaines de milliers de
civils et de soldats tués voilà le
terrible bilan de la folie meurtrière
déclenchée voici près d'un an par le
sinistre Poutine qui a fait le choix
irresponsable d'envahir l'Ukraine le
choix du sang et des larmes violant les
règles du droit international mettant en
péril la sécurité en Europe relançant
une désastreuse course aux armements ce
constat implacable nous rappelle une
évidence trop peu évoquée en ces heures
de déchaînement de violence notre seul
horizon doit être celui de la paix oui
la paix sans que cette exigence ne
puisse être perçue comme un signe de
capitulation la France doit t'aider
l'Ukraine et notre pays n'a passé
d'étendre son soutien militaire
humanitaire et financier
mais madame la Première ministre le
conflit figé depuis l'automne connaît
des mouvements inquiétants depuis
plusieurs semaines avec la perspective
d'une offensive russe de grande ampleur
qui pourrait aligner jusqu'à un
demi-million de nouveaux conscrits le
président Poutine est habité par les
idées de destruction et de reddition de
l'Ukraine engagé dans une guerre qui n'a
aucun sens politique ou économique sauf
à vouloir reconstituer le glacis
soviétique un fil même ténu de
communication avec l'agresseur a été
maintenue depuis le début du conflit
mais les espoirs de retrouver une porte
de sortie négociée à court terme
s'amenuise devant l'intransigeance russe
bien sûr aucune négociation n'est
possible tant que l'Ukraine est sous les
bombes
la réforme des retraites reste le sujet
central à l'Assemblée nationale les
passes d'armes se succèdent lors des
questions au gouvernement les
oppositions réclament le retrait d'une
réforme qu'il juge injuste le
gouvernement fait bloque et accuse les
oppositions notamment la gauche
d'obstruction parlementaire
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin Lucas
pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre vous avez perdu la
bataille des retraites vous l'avez perdu
le 19 juin dernier quand les Françaises
et les Français ont refusé Emmanuel
Macron les pleins pouvoirs dans cette
assemblée pour appliquer son programme
présidentiel vous l'avez perdu dans la
rue devant un mouvement social uni
puissant vous l'avez perdu dans
l'opinion publique comme en atteste
quotidiennement les sondages qui nous
parviennent c'est le résultat de votre
pédagogie plus vous expliquez la réforme
plus les Français la comprennent plus
les Français la comprennent plus ils la
rejette et la combatte avec nous alors
madame la Première ministre ma question
est simple il n'est pas trop tard pour
apaiser le pays et éviter le blocage
quand allez-vous renoncer à voler aux
françaises aux Français deux années de
vie deux années de vie en bonne santé
quand allez-vous retirer votre réforme
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
si le député lucarne nous poser des
questions je vous en êtes aucune nous
avons un système de retraite qui est
déficiable 12 milliards 5 en 2027 de 15
milliards en 2030 de 20 milliards en
2035 et de 25 milliards en 2040 nous
avons un rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui dit qui
nous ne faisons rien le niveau de vie
des retraités par rapport à la
population active est-ce que vous
promettez au retraités actuel la
pauvreté et aux retraités futurs
l'absence de retraite
le mouvement social contre la réforme
des retraites bassons plein les députés
de la gauche réunis au sein de la nupes
relais la colère de la rue dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale les
séances de questions au gouvernement se
succèdent et se ressemblent dans une
ambiance électrique
la parole est à Monsieur Manuel Bompard
pour le groupe lf6 merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
ce mardi 7 mars fera date dans
l'histoire de France alors où je vous
parle plusieurs millions de personnes
défilent dans les rues des plus petits
communes aux grandes métropoles c'est le
pays tout entier qui se lève nous vivons
la plus grande journée de grève et de
manifestations depuis 50 ans alors où je
vous parle l'essentiel des trains des
métros et des bus ne circulent plus
aucune goutte de carburant ne sort des
raffineries les chaînes de l'industrie
sont à l'arrêt les centrales électriques
réduisent leur production et d'ores et
déjà des assemblées générales ont décidé
de poursuivre de poursuivre la grève
pour demain mais vous faites la sourde
oreille vous ignorez vous méprisez vous
mentez vous misez sur le découragement
votre question par son ton comme par son
fond et symptomatique de votre
positionnement politique
symptomatique parce que vous appelez au
blocage vous appelez pour reprendre
l'expression d'un responsable syndicale
à mettre l'économie à genoux mais mettre
l'économie à genoux c'est mettre les
travailleurs à genoux c'est mettre les
cases à genoux c'est mettre en
difficulté les petites entreprises c'est
mettre en difficulté les plus fragiles
dans notre société votre question elle
est aussi symptomatique parce que d'un
mot vous dites vous êtes seul la
première ministre n'est pas seule la
première ministre est accompagnée par
toute la majorité et elle est aussi
accompagnée au-delà de la majorité par
toutes celles et ceux qui en
responsabilité savent que ce que nous
faisons permet la pérennité du système
par répartition et permet de garantir la
solidarité intergénérationnelle et puis
enfin Monsieur le Député votre question
est symptomatique pour une troisième
raison vous faites le choix de
l'outrance vous faites le choix des
grandes déclarations vous faites le
choix du blocage et en réalité vous
répétez le choix de l'obstruction nous
avons fait le choix du débat et de la
discussion vous avez fait le choix de
l'obstruction vous avez fait le choix de
l'irresponsabilité et vous avez le faire
un choix qui est finalement d'esquiver
esquiver la responsabilité ne pas
regarder l'avenir ne pas faire face aux
enjeux notre majorité elle est
responsable pour vous
sur tous les bancs de l'hémicycle les
oppositions demandent des explications
au gouvernement sur les points les plus
sensibles de la réforme les carrières
longues la pénibilité la retraite
accordée aux femmes ou encore l'emploi
des seniors
vos intentions pour la réforme des
retraites nous les connaissons les
femmes paieront un lourd tribu le
ministre Franck Riester lui-même la
reconnu il a raison les femmes ont des
carrières ininterrompues doivent
travailler plus longtemps 19% doivent
atteindre l'âge d'annulation de la déco
pour liquider leur droit contre 10% pour
les hommes le bénéfice des trimestres de
maternité qui permet à de nombreuses
femmes de partir à taux plein à 62 ans
sera annulé par le report de l'âge légal
à 64 ans pour 100000 d'entre elles le
dispositif carrière longue et votre
désormais célèbre retraite à 1200 euros
ne concernera que très peu de femmes en
définitive votre réforme est encore plus
d'inégalités pour les femmes et si
finalement l'égalité salariale
permettant d'augmenter les cotisations
étaient une partie de la solution plutôt
que d'augmenter la durée de cotisation
agissez en permettant aux femmes de
gagner autant que les hommes et ainsi de
cotiser davantage ce qui serait
réellement une réforme de progrès une
réforme de gauche madame la première
ministre ma question est donc simple le
gouvernement va-t-il rejoindre Laurent
de ceux qui veulent faire de l'égalité
famome une réalité en renonçant à cette
réforme
inutile et injuste surtout pour les
femmes allez-vous agir pour l'égalité
salariale aujourd'hui plus que jamais
ces deux sujets sont liés vous dites
madame la député cette réforme pèse sur
les femmes je l'ai dit en 2030 l'effort
qui est demandé et parfaitement répartis
entre les deux sexes 50% pour les hommes
50% pour les femmes et nous allons aller
plus loin nous allons aller plus loin
pour faire en sorte qu'à l'initiative de
la majorité sénatoriale et avec le
soutien de la majorité présidentielle
nous puissions faire en sorte que les
femmes qui atteignent la durée
d'affiliation requise à 63 ans puisse
bénéficier d'une surcote ça n'enlèvera
rien au dispositif permettant aux femmes
de d'éviter la décote d'éviter la
difficulté du fait des trimestres
majorés mais ça permettra à celle que
une carrière complète de bénéficier
d'une surcote c'est quelque chose qui
est important et c'est quelque chose sur
lequel nous voulons travailler et puis
deux dernières remarques madame la
députés vous dites les femmes ont plus
souvent besoin que les hommes d'aller
jusqu'à 67 ans pour éviter la décote
c'est vrai mais ça amène deux remarques
de ma part la première c'est pour cela
que nous avons pour la première fois
alors que l'âge légal de départ est
relevé nous avons fait le choix de
maintenir l'âge de suppression de la
décote à 67 ans pour justement limiter
cet effet qui amène les femmes aller
plus loin et puis assumons ensemble nos
responsabilités surtout quand elles sont
partagées qu'est-ce qui fait une
carrière hachée qu'est-ce qui fait une
carrière incomplète c'est la durée de
cotisation en 2013 comme moi vous avez
voté son allongé son allongement
qu'en est-il des mesures pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt la prise
en compte de la pénalité de la
pénibilité des pénibilités devraient-je
dire est-elle garantie en particulier
pour les carrières dites actives la
situation des femmes est-elle enfin
améliorée après toutes ces réformes
qu'ils ont ignoré vont-elles être enfin
rétablies dans leurs droits à savoir une
retraite digne vous savez à quel point
le groupe démocrate y a travaillé enfin
allons-nous améliorer le taux d'emploi
des seniors dont deux tiers ne
travaillaient plus pour mettre ainsi un
terme à se gâchis humain tous ces points
madame première ministre sont
l'assurance du respect de notre contrat
social je vous remercie nous arriverons
dans quelques jours au terme d'un long
processus de travail de concertation et
de débats
il y a un an le président de la
République s'est présenté au suffrage
des Français en portant l'engagement
d'une réforme pour garantir l'avenir de
nos retraites par répartition à
l'automne 2022 avec le ministre du
Travail Olivier du socle nous avons
lancé des concertations avec les
organisations syndicales patronales et
les groupes parlementaires ils nous ont
permis de présenter un projet de loi
enrichi par leur propositions et je sais
combien avec vos collègues de la
majorité monsieur le Président Mattei
vous y avez contribué depuis le débat
parlementaire se poursuit au Sénat le
texte a été discuté jusqu'au bout et
adopter en fin de semaine dernière
l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale a déjà consacré
plus de temps à débattre de ce projet
que lors des deux précédentes réforme
des retraites même si l'obstruction
organisée a accaparer le débat
mais mesdames mais mesdames et messieurs
les députés
mais mesdames et messieurs les députés
dans cette assemblée une majorité existe
qui croit au travail y compris au
travail des seniors
après deux mois de bataille politique et
d'opposition dans la rue le gouvernement
utilise l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution pour faire passer sa
réforme des retraites sans vote à
l'Assemblée nationale un épilogue
parlementaire qui déclenche les foudres
de l'opposition en réponse la première
ministre Martel le même message une
réforme nécessaire adoptée après 175
heures de débat
Président vous aiderez car de Français
sur trois souhaitent votre départ vous
céderez car passer en force contre le
peuple les syndicats le Parlement relève
d'une folie vous céderez car le risque
d'un débordement de colère est déjà trop
grand vous céderez car la police seule
ne parviendra pas à faire régner l'ordre
vous céderez car un caprice du président
ne mérite pas de menacer la paix civile
du pays
vous céderez car votre réforme des
retraites relève d'un choix politique et
qu'il est possible d'en faire un tout
autre vous céderez car au fond vous en
lisez le pays dans une crise de régime
inutile
vous céderez car nous serons nombreux
jeudi pour la censure populaire et
toujours plus nombreux encore
vous céderez car la dignité des gens n'a
pas de prix oui vous céderez car il n'y
aura pas de retour à la normale possible
sans céder vous céderez mais alors
qu'est-ce que vous laisserez vous
céderez mais vous aurez abîmé comme
rarement la parole politique
instrumentaliser la Constitution à des
fins autoritaires dévoyé comme jamais la
démocratie parlementaire confondue avec
une roulette russe quand ce n'est pas un
jeu de pile ou face
bafoué la démocratie sociale en traitant
les syndicats comme des figurants
attaquer le droit de grève et de
manifestations à coups de réquisition et
de répression fait honte à la France à
l'international
vous céderez et au moment où vous
céderez il sera déjà trop tard car vote
de votre pouvoir il ne restera que des
débris madame la Première ministre un
peu de courage il ne reste pas Emmanuel
Macron plus beaucoup d'options retrait
du texte ou retour devant le peuple
combien de temps encore le président de
la République va-t-il nous faire perdre
du temps avant de céder
les mots ont un sens
autoritarisme c'est le mot que vous
employez pour parler de notre
Constitution
illégitime
illégitime c'est le mot que vous
utilisez pour décrire le Parlement le
débat les institutions
assassin c'est l'insulte qui a hurlé
l'un de vos députés en attaquant le
ministre du Travail
très dégoût fureur ce sont vos paroles
hier dans un registre haineux qui est
désormais votre habitude s'il vous plaît
censure populaire ce sont les mots de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon appelant au
soulèvement face au Parlement
madame la Présidente panneau hier soir
votre violence verbale à déborder dans
la rue mais alors là sans surprise
sans surprise vous n'avez plus de mots
pour condamner les violences au
contraire vous continuez sans relâche
votre attaque systématique des
institutions républicaines vous vous en
prenez aux policiers et aux gendarmes
vous remettez en cause leur travail leur
comportement doit être exemplaire et ils
le savent tous tout signalement et
systématiquement examiner pour ma part
je veux le rendre hommage il nous
protège il protège nos institutions et
l'ordre républicain
je veux dire notre solidarité aux 400
policiers et gendarmes blessés ces
derniers jours dont 42 cette nuit je
veux saluer enfin nos sapeurs-pompiers
qui ont été fortement mobilisés alors
madame la Présidente panot moi aussi
j'ai quelques mots à partager que vos
dernières interventions et l'attitude de
votre groupe ces dernières semaines
m'ont rappelé
le premier le premier c'est duplicité
c'est vous entendre vous plaindre de ne
pas avoir pu aller jusqu'au bout du
texte que vous avez tout fait pour
bloquer
vous avez empêché avec même la première
ministre le vote parce que vous alliez
le perdre vous alliez perdre ce vote
devant la représentation nationale alors
Monsieur le Ministre rendez-vous
utile accompagné madame borne vers la
sortie
mais sommes-nous
monsieur le ministre merci madame la
Présidente il y a une chose qui est sûre
dans ce que vous avez dit c'est
peut-être la seule chose de vrai ça
n'est pas vous qui a d'empêcher le débat
puisque vous avez été muet pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez été mué parce que
votre projet il coûte 26 milliards
d'euros qu'il aurait ruiné les Français
et ruiner les petits retraités
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre c'est avec une extrême gravité
que je m'adresse à vous alors même que
le pays vous signifie que votre coup de
force sur la retraite à 64 ans et non
seulement inadmissible mais dangereux
quand le peuple rejette aussi
massivement votre réforme quand toutes
les organisations syndicales font front
communs quand le Parlement est piétiné
c'est la France et c'est la République
que vous abîmez non seulement vous
plongez le pays dans une crise profonde
mais en plus vous faites le choix d'user
de la matraque de la répression
syndicale et des réquisitions pour faire
taire maintenant la contestation je vous
le dis solennellement madame la Première
ministre
face au chaos que vous provoquez par vos
choix nous ne répondrons pas par le
chaos nous appelons au respect du peuple
de la démocratie sociale au respect des
organisations syndicales avec qui vous
ne dialoguez plus depuis le 10 janvier
et nous appelons aussi au respect du
Parlement
170 députés issus de 5 groupes ont
déposé cet après-midi un recours au
Conseil constitutionnel 255
parlementaires
issus de 9 groupes du Sénat de
l'Assemblée nationale ont aussi des
pesées une demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée inscrit dans notre
Constitution allez vous dire aussi que
cette démarche serait-il légitime rien
que ces recours doivent vous conduire à
ne pas promulguer la loi
respectez-les
respectez-nous respectez ces millions de
salariés encore en grève pacifiquement
et qui manifesteront ce jeudi 23 et j'en
profite pour appeler les Français à
faire de cette journée la plus puissante
des mob ilisations de notre pays madame
la Première ministre
rendez les armes nous voulons la paix la
paix civile retirez votre réforme des
retraites les Français ont besoin de
retrouver la confiance dans leur
démocratie dans leur République vous
aviez utilisé une expression vous avez
utilisé l'expression la répression par
la matraque
c'est une expression que je ne peux
accepter que le gouvernement n'accepte
pas et cette expression monsieur le
député me permet de dire le soutien de
tout le gouvernement aux forces de
police qui assure l'ordre qui ramène
l'ordre dans les rues de Paris comme
dans les rues des autres villes qui se
l'autorité du ministre de l'Intérieur
protège les bâtiments publics protège
les élus et leur travail doit-elle
saluer monsieur le député leur travail
doit-elle salué parce que le maintien de
l'ordre c'est aussi le maintien de la
liberté et le maintien de la capacité
d'expression libre de chacun la deuxième
chose Monsieur le Député que je ne peux
partager c'est lorsque vous dites que le
Parlement a été piétiné comment dire que
le Parlement était piétiné alors qu'il y
a eu 175 heures de débats que le seul
moment où le Parlement n'a pas pu
délibérer c'est lorsque les groupes de
gauche de cette assemblée organisé une
obstruction systématique pour empêcher
l'Assemblée nationale de délibérer et
privé les députés de ce qui fait
l'essence de leur fonction c'est-à-dire
voter
après le recours à l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution pour faire passer la
réforme des retraites des violences
éclatent au sein des cortèges de
manifestations affrontement en violant
aussi à Sainte Soline dans les Deux
Sèvres lors d'une manifestation
interdite ces deux événements s'invitent
aux questions d'actualité
ce samedi 25 mars à Sainte Soline nos
efforts nos forces de l'ordre ont été la
cible de plusieurs milliers d'individus
radicaux violents
infiltrés dans les manifestation non
autorisée contre les réserves de
substitution et armées de cocktail
Molotov de mortier de H et d'autres
projectiles très dangereux
face à cette violence au résultat d'une
tristesse accablante nous avons assisté
à des scènes d'affrontements choquantes
au cours desquelles des véhicules de nos
forces de l'ordre ont été incendiés et
de nombreuses personnes blessées ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous nous
indiquer quelle mesure rendez-vous
prendre face à ces événements d'une
violence inacceptable personne n'est au
dessus de nos lois et de telles
affrontements ne peuvent et ne doivent
se reproduire quelle mesure
prévoyez-vous vis-à-vis des
organisateurs tels que les collectifs
bassines non merci ou encore
l'association le soulèvement de la terre
qui était à l'initiative de cette
manifestation bien qu'elle soit
interdite je vous remercie monsieur le
député vous m'interrogez dans votre
département vous le savez ce week-end
c'est passé des événements
inqualifiables la préfète des
Deux-Sèvres depuis plusieurs jours
depuis le 17 mars avait interdite la
manifestation à Sainte-Soline et aux
abords de sainte Soline et par deux
conférences de presse et par celle de
Monsieur le Procureur de la République
chacun connaissait cette interdiction de
manifestation
nous avons parce que nous savions
malheureusement depuis six mois et le
premier événement à sainte-soling qui
avait déjà fait naître 61 gendarmes
blessés dans plusieurs très gravement
des confrontations radicales avec comme
vous l'avez dit des violences
inacceptables contre les biens et
surtout contre les personnes évidemment
les 47 militaires de la gendarmerie mais
également plusieurs manifestants et je
veux aussi avoir une pensée pour ceux
qui luttent pour la vie en ce moment et
pour les blesser et je veux dire bien
évidemment notre compassion à chacune et
chacun puisque aucune cause ne peut
justifier ces violences cependant je
constate comme vous l'extrême violence
de certains groupuscules ont les
services de renseignement des montres
qui sont à la fois fichés par les
services de renseignement parfois depuis
de très nombreuses années et qui sont
responsables de grandes violences et je
pense notamment évidemment au groupement
de faits des soulèvements de la terre
plusieurs envahissements d'entreprises
plusieurs exactions fortes contre les
forces de l'ordre plusieurs destructions
de biens plusieurs des centaines de
gendarmes ou de policiers blessés
plusieurs en effet appel à
l'insurrection j'ai donc décidé
d'engager la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre
que je proposerai après contradictoire à
un prochain conseil des ministres
depuis plusieurs semaines des millions
de Français manifestent calmement
encadré de façon responsable par les
organisations syndicales malheureusement
dans ces cortèges ce sont glissés
des militants d'extrême gauche dont le
seul objectif et de piller de brûler de
tuer du flic dans ce contexte nos
policiers nos gendarmes se trouvent en
première ligne plus de 500 d'entre eux
ont été blessés à l'occasion de la
manifestation de jeudi dernier ou samedi
à Sainte solide 500 policiers au
gendarmes qui garantissent l'ordre
républicain nous leur devons une
reconnaissance nous leur devons un
hommage républicain pour leur dire que
sans eux la République ne tiendrait pas
bravo
les policiers mais sans surprise
constateront que sur les bancs de
l'extrême gauche cet hommage n'est pas
accepté et vous refusez de vous y
associer comme Madame panot ce matin
indiqué de façon scandaleuse comme
manifestant était mort instrumentalisant
ce conflit social à des visées
extrémistes alors oui je le dis nous
demandons dans ce contexte des mesures
fortes le ministre de l'Intérieur vient
d'en parler mais cela ne suffit pas les
mots ne suffisent plus il faut des actes
il faut des actes concrets ces individus
ces milistent extrêmes d'Oches sont
connus il faut aujourd'hui les éradiquer
il faut changer de cadre monsieur le
présidentiottier merci pour les mots que
vous avez eu pour les policiers pour les
gendarmes je veux aussi penser aux
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont été pris à
parti encore ce matin d'ailleurs dans
l'ouest de la France
je veux souligner monsieur le député
cioti que les préfets de la République
les policiers et les gendarmes et les
organisations syndicales ont su
organiser oui grandes journées de
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites sans qu'il n'y ait aucun
incident majeur dans notre pays avec des
millions de personnes vous le savez bien
partout sur le territoire national et je
veux
des millions cumulés madame la présente
Le Pen ne vous inquiétez pas
ce qui est important de souligner c'est
que lorsque l'extrême gauche est l'ultra
gauche c'est mêler depuis le 16 mars
dernier
aux manifestations sauvages non déclaré
s'attaquant au carrest syndicaux
s'attaquant aux policiers aux gendarmes
s'attaquant des préfectures à des
commissariats à des hôpitaux à des
tribunaux à des permanences politiques
et des parlementaires menaçants les îles
de la République alors oui oui le chaos
cherche à s'installer est-ce que je
regrette comme vous monsieur cioti c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas uneanimité dans la
classe politique pour dénoncer ces
groupes factieux qui veulent mettre à
bas la République parce que l'ultra
gauche ne veut pas attaquer la réforme
des retraites elle veut attaquer la
République
le train gauche te veux pas attaquer le
gouvernement elle veut attaquer les
policiers et ça fait 8 groupuscules ou
associations d'extrême gauche que je
propose à la dissolution toute validé
par le Conseil d'État nous continuerons
grâce au service de renseignement et
j'espère avec l'unanimité de la
présentation nationale
au printemps 2023 la question sensible
de la violence contre les élus résonne
dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale les députés rendent hommage à
Yannick Morez mère démissionnaire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins en
Loire-Atlantique sa voiture et son
domicile ont été incendiés parce qu'il
souhaitait transférer un centre
d'accueil pour migrants d'un point à
l'autre de sa commune
au nom de mon groupe je souhaite avoir
une pensée émue et exprimer un soutien
que j'espère unanime dans notre
assemblée pour Yannick Moret mère de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins à Loire-Atlantique
contraint
contraint à la démission à la suite de
l'attaque inexcusable de son domicile
parle de la part de l'extrême droite
nous devons condamner toutes les
violences en particulier celles contre
les mers et élu locaux s'attaquaient aux
élus c'est s'attaquer aux vivre ensemble
c'est s'attaquer au fondement de notre
contrat social c'est s'attaquer à la
République
nous avons découvert il y a plusieurs
semaines avec un certain effroi le
témoignage du maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins faisant état de
nombreux intimitations violentes qu'il a
subit il a expliqué avoir reçu comme
seul soutien de l'État un unique coup de
téléphone de la part du porte-parole du
gouvernement le jour où sa maison a été
incendié il affirme n'avoir obtenu
aucune protection politique bien qu'il
en ait fait la demande de manière
répétée la réponse de l'État n'a pas été
à la hauteur du danger alors que c'est à
l'état de protéger et c'est l'État qui
voulait mettre en place une cada sur sa
commune les prises de position au
gouvernementale en soutient aux élus
victimes de violence au-delà d'être
tardives ne sont pas suffisantes ces
violences se multiplient que ce soit à
Callac que ce soit un peu gris scante ou
dans bien d'autres lieux qu'on vient de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour retrouver une
société apaisée avec des relations
respectueuses entre les administrés leur
représentants qu'ils soient élus locaux
parlementaires madame la Première
ministre qu'envisagez-vous pour faire
cesser ses violences et assurer au
quotidien la sécurité des sans lesquels
notre démocratie ne pourra pas
fonctionner
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
gue monsieur Gérald
de domaine
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Molac au nom du gouvernement au nom de
la première miss qui s'est exprimée au
nom du Président de la République nous
voulons vous associer évidemment aux
propos que vous allez tenus de soutien
envers Monsieur le Maire de Saint-Brévin
et de tous les élus de la République
quel que soit leur conviction et leur
bord politique ils sont menacés dans
leur fonction dans leur intimité et
évidemment aucune cause
aucune cause ne mérite la violence
contre les élus quel qu'il soit je veux
monsieur le député vous dire évidemment
que nous avons tous été très choqué non
seulement des attaques connues Monsieur
le Maire mais de nombreux maires en
France ils connaissent aujourd'hui des
menaces quelle que soit les raisons pour
lesquelles ils s'engagent pour faire
respecter l'ordre public sur leur
territoire pour faire respecter
l'environnement ou leur vie et la vie
économique ou encore très récemment
lorsqu'il lutte contre les trafics en
tout genre monsieur le député bien sûr
lorsqu'un maire est menacée quand sa
famille est menacée bien sûr lorsque on
prend gravement atteinte à sa vie
personnelle en mettant des photos sur
les réseaux sociaux en le menaçant
physiquement en brûlant sans doute ces
véhicules et c'est bien et lorsqu'il
démissionne c'est un échec pour la
République et nous pourrions toujours
faire mieux mieux dans la prévention
avec Christophe Béchu en charge des
collectivités locales et Dominique Faure
je sais que tous les jours ils sont au
côté de de ces élus locaux très
courageux mieux dans la protection et
c'est le cas bien sûr du ministère de
l'intérieur des policiers et des
gendarmes et mieux dans la condamnation
et c'est sûr que le travail du garde des
sceaux aujourd'hui en lien avec les élus
et très important puisque vous savez que
les enquêtes judiciaires ont été
ouvertes immédiatement par le procureur
de la République et qui ne m'appartient
pas ici de les commenter je veux
cependant dire que Olivier Véran membres
du gouvernement a appelé le maire de
Saint-Brévin la gendarmerie a pris trois
fois contact avec lui sans doute que la
protection n'était pas à la hauteur de
ce qu'il attendait sinon il n'aurait pas
démissionné sans doute nous pouvons nous
améliorer mais soyez certains qu'il n'y
a pas la main qui tremblent contre tous
ceux qui menacent les élus de la
République madame la Première ministre
ancien maire de Saint-Brévin je veux
redire ici notre émotion à la démission
du maire actuel Yannick Morez après une
violente agression et je lui redis toute
notre solidarité
[Applaudissements]
le 27 juin 2023 Naël 17 ans est tué par
un tir policier lors d'un contrôle
routier à Nanterre sa mort déclenche des
violences urbaines sans précédent depuis
20 ans en France c'est la question
numéro 1 à l'Assemblée nationale
la parole est à Madame Sabrina c'est
bailli pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ce matin à Nanterre un mineur
de 17 ans a été tué à bout portant après
un contrôle routier j'adresse bien sûr à
la famille au proche de la victime non
plus sincères condoléances tout comme le
maire de Nanterre Patrick Jarry je
souhaite que les enquêtes ouvertes par
la justice et l'IGPN permettent de faire
au plus vite toute la lumière sur les
circonstances exactes de ce drame
monsieur le ministre nous reconnaissons
tout comme vous l'action difficile
risquée que même les forces de l'ordre
partout dans notre pays ils sont bien
souvent les premiers à répondre face aux
dangers mais l'usage des armes ne peut
et ne doit se faire que dans des cas
très précis qui représentent un danger
vital pour le dépositaire de la force
publique les images de Nanterre ce matin
sont terribles contrairement à ce qu'on
peut affirmer certains médias aucun
policier ne se trouvait devant le
véhicule lorsque celui-ci était en
mouvement leur intégrité physique
n'était manifestement pas menacée et le
tir à bout portant ne semble absolument
pas proportionné au délit commis non le
jeune n'a pas foncé sur les policiers
comme l'affirme les professionnels de la
récupération politique à l'extrême
droite de cette hémicycle nous avons sur
l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux une vidéo
des montants catégoriquement cette
version cette affaire n'est
malheureusement pas isolée pire nous
constatons une hausse des cas comme à
Nice ou encore à Paris à l'automne
dernier depuis cela s'accélère avec deux
blessés graves en Seine-Saint-Denis les
16 mai et 3 juin et un nouveau tués le
14 juin à Angoulême aussi Monsieur le
Ministre j'aimerais vous poser une
question pourquoi dans notre République
le refus d'obtompaire est peut-être
passible d'une balle dans la poitrine ou
dans la tête auquel cas pourriez-vous
nous préciser qui parmi notre pôle
population est soumis à cette loi
d'exception pour nous il est urgent de
revenir sur la loi du 28 février 2017
cette loi est trop ambiguë dans sa
formulation et permet aux policiers une
lecture très discutable quant à l'usine
l'usage du feu monsieur le ministre si
le refus d'obtempérer est un délit qui
est passible de trois ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amende il n'est pas possible de la
peine de mort
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la présidente madame
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée ce matin en effet à Nanterre
deux motards de la DOPC de la préfecture
de police ont procédé un contrôle nous
ne connaissons pas sauf les images
extrêmement choquantes que j'ai vu
personnellement comme beaucoup de
Français les conditions exactes puisque
les policiers en ce moment sont
auditionnés par les services de la
justice deux enquêtes ont été confiées à
l'IGPN et évidemment je veux aussi dire
que c'est un drame que ce jeune
conducteur de 17 ans soit mort des
suites de ce contrôle manifestement je
veux moi aussi comme le maire de
Nanterre que j'ai eu au téléphone en
début d'après-midi donc je salue aussi
les paroles républicaines qu'il a porté
médiatiquement avoir le plus rapidement
possible pour la famille de ce jeune
homme pour la ville de Nanterre mais
aussi pour la police nationale et pour
ses policiers les résultats de cette
enquête en respectant évidemment les
procédures judiciaires je veux aussi
vous dire ici que je suis très attaché à
la protection de l'innocence des accusés
et notamment de celui qui a tiré qui est
policier qui aura à rendre compte devant
son administration et devant la justice
de ses actes mais je ne suis pas juge je
ne suis pas procureur de la République
madame et je veux aussi être attentif à
la présomption des fonctionnaires de 197
fonctionnaires de police je pense
cependant madame permettez-moi de ne pas
être totalement d'accord avec la fin de
votre question depuis la loi 2017 j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire dans de très
nombreuses échanges ici qui a eu moins
de tirs et il y a eu moins de cas
mortels qu'avant 2017 je suis désolé de
lire madame que dans de très nombreux
cas malheureusement des policiers et des
gendarmes sont morts de refus
d'obtempérer et dans de très nombreux
cas il s'agit pas de mélanger avec celui
de ce matin manifestement ce sont des
familles de policiers et de gendarmes
qui pleurent leurs enfants alors non
bien sûr le refus nous intérêt ne peut
pas être accepté mais il n'est pas non
plus bien évidemment capable d'accepter
que des policiers tirent à vous portant
sur des jeunes hommes ou des jeunes
femmes quel que soit l'âge d'ailleurs
des conducteurs et vous dire qu'on doit
respecter le deuil des familles mais la
présomption innocence des policiers
[Applaudissements]
la représentation nationale demande des
réponses à ces violences urbaines qui
ont touché près de 500 villes en France
le gouvernement lui fustige le refus de
certains de condamner clairement les
violences urbaines l'annonce début
juillet d'un projet de loi pour
reconstruire le plus rapidement possible
ce qui a été détruit ramène un peu de
Concorde à l'Assemblée nationale
notre pays a vécu ces derniers jours des
heures effroyables rien rien ne peut
justifier de s'attaquer à des écoles à
des bibliothèques à des locaux
d'associations qui œuvrent pour le bien
commun nos concitoyens voient leurs
voitures brûlées des commerçants leur
magasin pillés des policiers des élus et
parfois même de simples passants qui se
trouvent au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment sont attaqués sauvagement je
tiens d'ores et déjà à saluer au nom du
groupe horizon et apparentez le travail
exceptionnel réalisé par nos forces de
secours et de sécurité elles ont souvent
été mobilisées sur des territoires qui
n'étaient pas les leurs dans les
conditions extrêmement difficiles que
nous connaissons tous
nous souhaitons aussi rendre hommage à
l'engagement sans faille dont font
preuve nos élus de terrain qui refusent
de reculer face aux menaces et
agressions mes chers collègues il n'y a
aucune revendication sociale à trouver
dans ces agissements inacceptables
aucune colère légitime aucune excuse
mais seulement un acte des actes de
Sécession d'une minorité qui rejette
toute forme d'autorité avec vous
monsieur le Président Marc Angeli avec
l'ensemble des députés de la majorité
avec toutes celles et ceux qui veulent
construire des solutions nous refuserons
les caricatures et les idées toutes
faites notre objectif c'est l'efficacité
dans les réponses ce sont les solutions
pour les habitants des quartiers pour
les habitants de tous nos territoires et
pour notre jeunesse notre ambition c'est
l'unité de la République je vous
remercie
ma question s'adresse à Christophe bichu
le ministre de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre entre
les 27 juin et le 6 juillet il y a eu
des très nombreuses dégradations des
violences très fortes dans ces pays et
nous les avons quasiment unanimement
condamnée je regrette que quelques amis
de Monsieur Mélenchon ne l'ai pas fait
c'est violent et faisait suite vous le
savez à la mort de sujet de Noël et
c'est violence elles ont touché des
symboles de la république des écoles des
bibliothèques des mairies même un bus
médicalisé c'est violent sont
inacceptables parce que elles sont le
fait de certains qui veulent le chaos
mais il n'y a pas de place pour le chaos
alors Monsieur le Ministre j'ai été
également indigné des voir que le
week-end dernier des députés insoumis
étaient présents à une manifestation
interdite parce que lorsqu'on vote la
loi en semaine on la respecte le
week-end alors monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre il s'agit
maintenant de reconstruire ces symboles
de la république de faire en sorte que
ces bâtiments publics ces lieux
d'accueil on soit capable demain de
montrer que c'est pas l'impuissance que
tu as rendez-vous mais au contraire
l'efficacité calories vous faire en
matière d'urbanisme pour simplifier les
procédures pression de la République a
pris un engagement
celui que nous puissions évoquer un
texte d'urgence pour accélérer cette
reconstruction
le Parlement sera soumis d'un projet de
loi d'habilitation sur ordonnance qui
sera présentée au Conseil des ministres
qui comprendra trois articles un pour
accélérer sur l'aménagement un pour
faciliter les règles en termes de
commandes publiques et le troisième pour
poser la question des financements ce
qui va se passer dans les prochaines
semaines monsieur le député Vigier c'est
précisément un rendez-vous un
rendez-vous pour faire en sorte que nos
condamnations quasi unanimes dans cette
hémicique de ces violences elle
s'accompagne par les moyens concrets de
pouvoir permettre au maire de restaurer
les services publics le plus vite
possible
il y a maintenant un peu plus d'une
semaine les Françaises et les Français
ont été les témoins de scènes d'une
violence inouïe 12000 voitures brûlées
105 incendies et dégradation de mairie
168 attaques d'écoles 17 atteintes aux
élus la lecture de ces chiffres témoigne
de la gravité des exactions commises je
vous parle depuis des territoires ruraux
comme le mien qui n'ont pas participé à
ses émeutes mais aussi depuis les zones
touchées ou beaucoup ont des approuvé et
vu avec effarmment ce déchaînement ou en
sommes-nous aujourd'hui pourriez-vous
monsieur le ministre détaillez la
réponse pénale que les tribunaux ont
apporté au récentes émeutes je vous
remercie entre le 27 juin et le 13
juillet
1278 jugements ont été prononcés avec
95% de condamnations et souvent avec
mandat de dépôt plus de 1300 déferments
au parquet 905 personnes ont fait
l'objet d'une comparution immédiate 1056
personnes ont été condamnées à une peine
d'emprisonnement 90% des condamnés dont
742 une peine d'emprisonnement ferme
62%. le quantum moyen ferme s'élève à
8,2 mois près de 600 personnes ont été
incarcérées 608 mineurs ont été déférés
la justice a répondu présent pour faire
revenir l'ordre républicain aux côtés
des policiers des gendarmes mais après
30 ans d'abandon elle a besoin que vous
répondiez présents tous les républicains
sur ces bancs de gauche à droite en
votant dans quelques heures là aussi
storique de plus de 7,5 milliards
d'euros du budget de la justice merci
monsieur le ministre
et ce 18 juillet marque la dernière
séance de questions au Gouvernement
quelques jours plus tard l'Assemblée
nationale suspendra ses travaux pour la
coupure estivale un système numéro des
grands débats à très vite sur LCP pour
revoir une autre séance
[Musique]